à 1h30 de moscou veni gorod une petite
ville tranquille où vivent de nombreux
retraités au centre d'un petit square un
monument aux soldats morts pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale ici le soutien à
l'opération spéciale se manifeste assez
discrète
dans l'épicerie dana
essentiellement des produits locaux
sur une étagère quelques bouteilles de
soda américain quasiment les seuls
produits importés la bouteille coûte 2
euros 40
ces boissons là ça a pas mal augmenté je
ne sais même pas si je vais en
recommandé ce à dire trop cher
la bouteille vient du kazakhstan
dans la plupart des commerces l'effet
des sanctions se traduit surtout par une
hausse des prix
alc a fait ça pas mal augmenté 15 à 20%
mais heureusement il ya de grandes
enseignes comme mcdonald's qui ont fermé
du coup j'ai récupéré une partie de
leurs clients
l'enseigne de fast food a fermé ses
portes il y a trois semaines
mais certains secteurs souffrent
beaucoup plus dans ses garages en
périphérie de moscou entretenir sa
voiture devient un luxe surtout
lorsqu'on est amateur de grosses
berlines il y en a beaucoup en russie
l'entretien ça devient n'importe quoi il
faut compter 1000 euros pour une vidange
sur une allemande de gamme
et pièces de rechange en ont encore mais
les prix ont été multipliés par trois ou
quatre
au quotidien les sanctions pénalisent
surtout les classes moyennes supérieures
et les jeunes urbains adepte d'un mode
de vie plus occidental